hello my name is rohn khanna and my
topic is transcriptomics analysis of
type 2 diabetes gene expression
diabetes is a disease defined by blood
group but blood glucose level
fluctuation
fluctuation in blood glucose level might
not result in major symptoms over a
short period of time
but chronic conditions may lead to
vascular complications
both micro and macro
diabetes is a group of metabolic
diseases characterized by
hyperglycemia resulting from defects in
insulin secretion insulin action
or both in the case of type 2 diabetes
it's both and in the case of type 1
diabetes it's insulin
action the chronic hyperglycemia of
diabetes is associated with long-term
damage
dysfunction and failure of different
organs especially eyes
kidneys nerves heart and blood vessels
in severe clear cases necrosis also
occurs
in fingers as well as sometimes
limbs
no cure for diabetes currently exists
but the disease can go into remission
remission means that the body does not
show any signs of diabetes because the
blood glucose level is regulated
although the disease is technically
still there
that is the symptoms do not show but the
cause is there
the ammunition consists of a1c levels
below six percent as a significant
factor a1c levels indicate a person's
blood sugar level over 3 months
type 2 diabetes and its
diagnosis
so an impaired insulin secretion is the
characterization of type 2 diabetes
this impaired insulin secretion from
pancreatic beta cells
is coupled with resistance of insulin in
tissues
of skeletal muscles adipose tissue and
liver
an elevated blood glucose level
diabetes can be diagnosed based on a
measure of fasting blood glucose and
or long-term levels of blood glucose
hba1c proportions
a more detailed method for measuring the
level of
glycemia is a2
a2r oral glucose tolerance test
or ogtt which also allows
the detection of impaired fasting
glycemia
ifg and impaired glucose tolerance
igt diabetes
a global pandemic
over the past few decades the prevalence
of diabetes has
exponentially increased worldwide the
statistics of 2017
shows that 425 million people
worldwide suffer from diabetic
conditions from
and from that number 77 million are
indians
this concludes that every sixth diabetic
patient
is an indian
the number of patients suffering from
diabetes is not
regressing but rather progressing
according to the leading researchers
and the international diabetic
federation
the international diabetes federation
has established that this number of
for 425 million can or may reach
629 million in the next two decades or
around
2045.
the prevalence of type 1 and type 2
diabetes cannot be studied or estimated
separately
as most of the studies are done with
type 1 and type 2 diabetes
both samples together
but one estimate shows that developing
developed countries
have 18 to 90 percent
of all the cases of type 2 diabetes
while 7
percent to 13 percent is estimated to
have type 1
there was also a small percentage of
individuals bearing other types of
diabetes such as
just such as gdm
or gestational diabetic medicine
which happens in pregnant women
the research question which i took was
i wanted to explore and study the
biomarkers for diabetes type 2 through
transcriptomic analysis
and to look at the pathways affected in
type 2 diabetes
the data data set i chose was obese
insulin resistant humans with
compensatory
hyper insulinemia
dissociate liposis from glycemia as
possible adaptive response for to
fatness now
what does that mean is that the data set
we are using
first of all is in our study is
available on geo
website under essential number of
gse141432
so the data asset is divided into two
groups
which is lean and ob sample and the ob
sample itself is divided
into two two groups as well
the overall design of this study was to
shed light on mechanisms driving
elevated levels of ffa and glycerol
in the affected or obese group
and for this study genome-wide rna
sequence analysis was performed
the sub and the tissue present was
subcutaneous white adipose tissue
and the sample was taken from lean
individuals or healthy or normal
individuals
obese obese insulin resistant
individuals as well as obese type 2
diabetes diagnosed subjects
the total number of lean individuals are
9 and the total number of
the diagnosed or obese individuals were
16. my sample size of
my total sample size was 25
the data set was an expression profiling
experiment
done by high throughput sequencing
and the link between obesity five blood
levels of free fatty acid
with type 2 diabetes is not completely
understood
and they investigated glucose
homeostasis
lipolysis in obese patients recently
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
the obese patients resistant to insulin
who were
non-diabetic subjects
and the lean individuals age sex body
composition and fasting insulin levels
were taken as parameters
the result of this study showed
that that the obese insulin
the resistant dissociate lipolysis from
glycemic control
now the methodology
analysis of the data was done through t
bioinfo server
the data was fed from ncbi website or
geo website
data set ascension number gse141432
the data we took had some unique
features
it had
this pro the data was divided as i said
the data was divided into two and then
further divided into the obese
sample was further divided into two
parts as well
through this we can understand my my
previous statement that
the studies done on ob
the study is done on diabetes and
obesity
always have type 1 and type 2 diabetes
together linked together or coupled
i couldn't find a data set purely of
type 2 diabetes or type 1 diabetes
the base the basic path we took was to
collect the data from rna sequence
done by other scientists to make sure it
was usable in our study
then we processed the data normalized it
and used it
for pc analysis and deg analysis
the results were then used for go
analysis
and finally we had our results
which will be further discussed later
the data taken had combined identity
after the pc analysis pc1 plus pc2 was
more than 60
and it had the data divided through body
classes body type classification
the pca or the principal component
analysis
deg differential express genes and go
gene ontology analysis were then done to
find out
highly expressed genes and important
pathways
pca analysis pipeline
the data was in the form of a matrix
file
where the values needed to be normalized
quantile normalization was done using
the t by infoserver pipeline
normalization is basically done to
remove the differences in the scale of
our data
provided and make a reference scale
which can be applied to all the data
at once and still preserve the original
meaning of the data
the quantile normalization is also done
to limit the maximum
and minimum or or the data we need to
use further
and helps in removing outliers to make
data cleaner and have less
signal to noise ratio in our pc analysis
we got four outliers two in the bottom
left and two in the
bottom right
and pca is a classic dimension reduction
approach
and it was used to construct linear
combinations of gene expression
and through this analysis pca scatter
plot graph was produced
[Music]
now the plot does not show any
considerable distinction between the two
groups
if we consider the outliers
and it was less fruitful than
anticipated
if but if we remove these two outliers
that are
as you can see here the bottom right
and the bottom left if we if we remove
these two outliers we can see
some distinction present in the lean and
the obese
types
the deg pathway and go pathway
now
the de sequence analysis is the analysis
of count data from rna sequence
for the detection of differentially
expressed genes
enrichment analysis identifies classes
of genes of proteins that
are over represented in a large set of
genes or proteins
and may have an association with the
disease phenotypes
now in this figure we can clearly see
the activation of immune response
adaptive immune response and
leukocyte migration carries the most
of the ratio of genes affecting type 2
diabetes
in this sample and the dots represent
the number of genes involved in the
pathway
the top three have depict i have as
depicted is
220 genes the p adjacent
p p value of the top three gene is one
point three eight
five eight five e raised to the power
tradition
now the volcano plot
in this volcano plot we can see the down
regulated genes
present the most downright regulated
gene
being the ankrd 20
a8p this gene is associated
with inflammation of subcutaneous
adipose tissue
the deg analysis shows the that
activation of
immune response is the most weighted
pathway which triggers adaptive immune
response
leukocyte migration now the second most
down regulated gene was slc 2782 gene
and this all this this gene also acts as
a biomarker for overweight development
and these findings are to be further
explored in their role of gene
expression of type 2 diabetes
now the conclusion the results shown in
the go enrichment analysis
show that the most down
down regulated gene that is a that is a
nkrd
20 a8p gene plays a vital role in
activation of the immune response
there is also plenty of proof that
suggests
the same that the by the slc 2782
is a biomarker for overview development
apart from these spx and
ttc36 are all were also distinguished
and are showing distinction in the
volcano plot
now spx levels are positively influenced
by glucose intolerance in pregnant women
with
gestational diabetes diabetes mellitus
or gdm while the decrease in control
why they decrease in control in women
without gdm
spx is a novel regulator of lipid
metabolism in murine
3t3 l1 as well and human adipocytes as
well
through this we conclude that the data
stands true
and the connection between adipose
adipocyte tissue and blood glucose level
regulation exists
thank you
you